that was extreme podcasting it really  was trying to get there before the dude  next to us who was definitely living in  his Studio would like wake and bake and  start making beats yeah all of a sudden  like mid record we just hear that deep  booming of a subwoofer like you're in a  movie theater and you hear the theater  next to you go like they're watching  like you know Marvel movie or something  like that and something crazy happens  and we were like mid recording we'd be  like no and all of a sudden he would  just start playing this crazy beat and  then weed smoke would just start wafting  through the vent  we're like oh no and then we get subtle  contact that's probably why we were  funnier than yeah we'd always start the  episode by chatting about politics and  intellectual stuff and it would just end  up at the end up us being like  yo what if a guy had two dicks that's  cute it's crazy yeah